i was actually really embarrassed when
we were recording that scene tom
holland's only been in a handful of
voice acting roles but he's sure done a
solid job of it we're taking a look at
his roles in those movies and a great
commercial about a beloved pig he once
voiced check it out number one brothers
inspire brothers tom holland took
inspiration from his younger brother i
basically just played my younger brother
paddy oh that's okay i gotta get going
but a little bit older is kind of how i
approach this role number two believe it
or not voice acting requires a ton of
physical acting which in onward
sometimes includes choking yourself
i'm not
tapping into any brain just let me go
hands are important to land those
inflections so you're not you're welcome
you're not coming
see all hands that's not something
anyone says
number three their first time meeting
happened to involve an escape room
because it was part of promotions for
the movie
tom holland and will smith never met in
their two and a half years of working on
spies in disguise because will did his
voice work in los angeles back up fanboy
and tom did his in new york never met
him
number four how could anyone ever be
intimidated by will smith it was indeed
intimidating for tom holland to record
the transformation scene in spies and
disguise because i have to do all these
like crazy different voices and so tom
found himself embarrassed in the process
the final stage
number five only tom had to alter his
accent not fair tom wasn't allowed to
use his own british accent in spies and
disguise because the character needed to
stick close to home to make the fish out
of water sensation work better one of
the directors nick bruno said our
conversations with tom earlier we all
felt as a group that it was better to
keep him just as a kid who grew up in dc
who experienced a tragic past so he's
still worldly in that sort of experience
it was left to the rest of the
characters in the film to color it with
their own authentic accents leaving it
broad in scope and no one notices them
number six who better to study for a
role than the family pet for pip and
doolittle tom holland took inspiration
from the best of the best the goodest of
the good girls i just based his
character
he even brought her to the premiere
have a kiss
can you spot the resemblances
number seven sometimes you have to get
over your embarrassment for a role
everyone's gonna get to see me be a dog
tom you're already a labrador it's okay
i wasn't actually that bad that came out
way better than i thought it would
number eight did you realize tom and tom
have shared the screen a couple of times
now in the movie lock tom holland played
the son of tom hardy's character in a
very short phone call cameo dad it's so
embarrassing um yeah what did you say
about coming home you know holland has
been in a ton of movies with other
marvel actors it's almost like it's
intentional tom hardy rdj chris pratt
can you think of any others number nine
there's a whimsical quality to the
british dub that the american dub just
doesn't have tom holland got his start
in animation by voicing a character in
the movie arietti this film's about a
boy
known as the secret world of arietti in
america but if you're not british you
probably can't claim that's the first
movie you recognize him from i suppose i
do because arietti was dubbed in both
british and american english the same
role was played by david henry who you
may remember as the oldest russo brother
in wizards of waverly place
number 10. entering into voice acting
through audio dubbing would be
intimidating tom found voice acting to
be very different from both theater and
film saying that projecting in theater
was very important whereas in film the
camera is in your face and you have to
be 100 true but with animation
specifically dubbing animation was quite
tricky to get all the timing right but
other than that he enjoyed working on it
number 11. he's played a pig a dog
what's next
percy pigs is a popular candy in britain
that's now 30 years old the mascot was
voiced for the first time ever by tom
holland hello tony fairy lady it took
him less than a second to agree to voice
percy saying i've loved percy pigs for
as long as i can remember he also
admitted that getting the snort right
was a challenge we think he did a good
job thank you he also joked that he
considered asking for a lifetime supply
of percy pigs number 12 what if a new
universe was created by casting someone
else to play tom holland's spider-man
odds are if it wasn't scheduling
conflicts which there would have been
many tom holland didn't join the cast to
record spider-man's lines for what if
because of his affiliations with sony
which may have made the endeavor pricier
and honestly there are a lot of actors
who can mimic holland pretty well so the
role went to hudson thames who really
admires tom holland by the way and he
wasn't trying to do an exact imitation
as he realized that was limiting his
ability to make artistic decisions about
the character in practice i guess it
seems like tom is pretty much a natural
at picking up that american accent now
and man he really finds himself
typecasted into the geekgear roles huh
not to say we don't love it because we
totally do and we're looking forward to
the next animated movie he does let's
fantasy cast tom in a role if he could
be the voice of any cartoon character
who do you think he would do a good job
of we'll go first hiccup from how to
train your dragon let us know your
thoughts in the comments and thanks for
hanging out with us here at the things